so okay so you're making all this
chemistry stuff and you're doing it for
YouTube it's all for YouTube right like
I mean like how would you describe your
content to someone like maybe some
people in your audience how would you
describe someone your content to people
who don't know what you do I think maybe
I should say how it started yeah oh yeah
yeah sure I'm saying that just for it to
make sense right
just random projects so as a kid I used
to build a lot of things right so I I
made like bike jumps and just I tried to
build a bunch of random stuff and then
somebody went to fireworks and
firecrackers
this is that's a big jump from like tiny
little jumps to explosive [ __ ] so
because in Canada you can't buy
firecrackers oh really well well are
they just like it's even more concerning
that you were playing with them yeah so
like whenever you get them could you buy
cracks as well sorry because you buy
black jumps as well they stop being as
uh yeah what age are we talking about
now when you're going to fire shockingly
young I'd say look I would never let a
kid do that like probably
just like the one story I have with my
neighbor too like we were trying to make
smoke I was trying to make smoke bombs
with my brother and we found the recipe
right in a book because you have to go
to the library to find these recipes
this is insane wait how old were you I
think I was nine or ten oh my God I
thought it was just like smoke bombs I
saw this is like your teenage years no
no no no I was like so we made it we've
like basically in the book it says even
heating don't overheat it my brother and
I are like oh we can get away with a
blow torch and we overheated it so it
went off in the garage and Smoke's
pouring everywhere and then to put it
out there's like ash all over my dad's
stuff and we freaked out and shot water
all over it's All Electronics but the
neighbors like do we need like the fire
department it's just smoke pouring and
we're like no it's okay we got this and
she's like okay so you were doing that
stuff at nine times
yeah we were doing I this is insane yeah
this is insanity I think and I gotta I
remember all the members are coming back
so like one thing we did was you know
like little caps you put in my cap guns
yeah oh Australia
where do you think I'm from of Britain
here
I'm not from a person
we cap guns is that we do have those we
have those paper Caps or the little
plastic ones you put in a fake gun and
oh oh just go back I thought you meant
the ones that they use in like the race
guns those are starter Pistons those are
much louder oh okay like the little kid
toys right yeah the ones that make the
sound but nothing comes out all right
yeah yeah okay yeah I think I know those
well I think we have those in the UK I
don't know some people I don't know
maybe I don't know but my I think I was
like 10 or 11. my friend and I would we
found that you could take the paper caps
you could cut them all up and I'd pack
them in like really tightly and you can
put them in a paintball gun and then
shoot it and explode where did you get a
paintball gun from oh I got it at the
store my parents let me buy all this
what the [ __ ] your parents are so lucky
that you still have all your limbs how
are you not maimed because my dad I mean
I think the big thing is my dad the
reason we did it because my dad liked
firecrackers and he liked all this stuff
and I think the reason that we didn't
get hurt was because our first
experience was he taught us everything
so he would be like right the thing like
you'd be like never light a firecracker
and throw it because as a kid he's like
I don't think his friends ever lost
their fingers but he's like we he was we
had some close calls and I think your
friend did lose like a piece of so he's
like no you don't do that you light and
run yeah so like he taught us a lot of
that stuff and we like BB guns at like
10 but he's like always wear safety
glasses like we learned all our guns
this is a gun where's some glasses he
was always there with us light and run
is that the official safety regulation
just slide and run just lie and run I
just if you light it you're not holding
it okay so sir okay so you're doing that
and then in the library there was a yeah
I never even like it this is a huge
tangent yeah no it's just there's no
internet at the time so but in the
library there was a book that taught you
how to make smoke bombs well Loosely
they just kind of said like smoke bombs
are made using this oh and you just
extrapolated it and you're like oh well
I can get that getting actually not
remember getting potassium nitrate which
is also called salt as you do we
couldn't buy it we couldn't buy it but I
don't even know what you buy now well I
know you just buy it online now like
eBay and stuff but my dad was like oh
your grandfather has some left I don't
know where he got it from me
what you realize everything you've said
so far is insane like this is all every
single beat of this story is insane this
story has got progressively more insane
the more you said I don't know I don't
know why he had it so this really old
like just it was just in our garage
do you want to make a smoke bomb and
then you get this book and you go to
your dad and you're like Hey Dad I want
to make the smoke bomb yeah
instead of you instead of your dad being
like no Sean come on that's silly he's
like oh yeah I'll I'll go get some
potassium potassium potassium nitrate
potassium nitrate of course yeah
naturally we did have a successful smoke
bomb after the first failed one
what happened what was the difference
between the failed one and the
successful well we overheated the first
one it went off while we're making it so
it's like it just spilled the house with
like the whole garage was your dad
watching you the first time you're
making the smoke no he was watching TV
so and then and then you [ __ ] it up so
badly he was like all right when you're
gonna do it again let me watch no I
think my brother and I just just said
okay we shouldn't have used the blood
targets
did your dad never like question me like
why is the garage smoking my dad is
inexplicably tolerant to like I think
it's because as a kid he my dad did some
crazy stuff as a kid yeah like the BB
guns he taught us how to shoot as a kid
he was like we had BB gun wars with no
safety glasses he goes you just shoot
each other and he goes I remember many
days I'd come home and you have to pick
BB's out with tweezers oh my God and I
was like if they hit your eyes like I
don't know I guess he went blind we
never thought about it and I was like
what about your mum this whole time she
just like for [ __ ] sake my mom got mad
at us for like everything I remember
there was one time my mom got mad okay
because only one this is this is gonna
sound even like it this is great
at this point so and just like these
memories coming back I talked to my
brother about this recently so we were
like fascinated by fire okay we were
like we were like what age is this
I think about the same age oh my nine
like nine ten ten oh my God so 9 10
Fascinate with fire okay what we like to
do like the idea I remember days I'd
come home so bad I would just go in my
garage I just pour like some paint
thinner into a can and just light it on
fire just because I was like I just like
burning stuff
so that's how people become awesomeness
so when we like this oh my God okay okay
okay so we would like to do is like soak
a rag in like some paint thinner or
something each bit of mulch off
no just listen we wrap it around like a
stick and we'd like to light it on fire
and just like swing it around as we were
like 10. so you made like the Torches
yeah yeah and so like what my this is
like the extra level I said my brother I
remember exactly what he did I found out
a way to like I remember exactly what he
did he like packed the rag he shot like
WD-40 on it or something and what he my
older brother did was he would like
I remember exactly he made like it would
be fiery but he was in a tube and he'd
like blow on it like smoke would come
out and he would use it to like leave
wasp an ass he'd use it to turn like oh
my God I don't remember if it ever
worked my mom my brother would do that
and then I would be like swinging around
like this fiery stick and we thought she
wasn't home and when she came home
because we'd light it in the front and
run to the bathroom
running through the backyard like giant
flaming sticks and my mom was like yeah
that's so that that's not your household
is just like Ed and Eddie like IRL just
like Phineas and Ferb but like it was
way more dangerous literally that scene
from Community with a [ __ ] childish
gambling yeah
everything's on fire
okay he didn't I think the big thing too
is like Iris like I respected my parents
yeah so when my mom caught us and told
us don't do that I think I did we did
stop like we stopped waiting I'd like to
think so we just you you would be an
interesting uh study I think like is it
is it not your own nature let's find out
what makes a kid become obsessed with
fire is it genetics or is it I think
everyone is obsessed with fire to a
point I mean you know it's [ __ ] it's
hypnotizing you know yeah especially
setting things on fire
I get you I get you okay with him he is
an awesomest I had a bad experience
though which I then didn't light
anything on fire for two years yeah I do
tell it's crazy uh
so the big change for me was when I hit
12 where you could buy a lighter right
all right what they just wouldn't sell
lighters if you're less than younger
than 12. why are they selling lettuce to
12 year olds
what a reason would a 12 everyone need a
lighter for I don't even know like your
dad's cigarette I like I like how you
know this presumably you went to the
store they would never let you buy it
and then did you go before 12. yeah
there you go you're too young and for
some reason
every birthday
yeah this is the yeah no there's just an
arbitrary age okay
okay the the law before you can buy
light is is I believe 16.
so I don't know why I thought 12 in my
head okay I don't think I've ever bought
a lighter
I didn't I didn't buy a ladder until I
was like in my 20s I've just bought
those kitchen lighters you know the ones
the long ones oh oh yeah yeah I bought
my first blowtorch when I was 12. oh my
[ __ ] okay okay all right
okay
so it's just like a choose your
adventure I gotta navigate which tangent
I want to go yeah yeah that one's
actually more the blowchart one's more
related to chemistry but all right okay
let's save the blowtorch then after okay
why did you become scared of five two
years oh so what happened was my friend
the one who I built like you know the
firecracker explodey paintball gun thing
yeah and as you do all a lot of this
stuff was with my friend right
um growing up and what happened was
laughs
we I know we just like to light a bunch
of stuff on fire and in in Montreal I
don't know if it happens elsewhere it
was around like sometime in the summer
yeah there would be
like there's big pollination thing and
there'd be everybody we covered in white
fluff but we found out that if you light
it on fire the fire just like travels as
like a wave down it right it's a massive
fire hazard I don't know how it even
like yeah it's just it's sitting around
all the time okay so it was really fun
we'd bike around if you found somebody
just light it on fire
but you'd always be careful and so like
oh yeah yeah okay I believe you I told
my friends
I told my friend like if you're gonna
light it make sure that you see the end
of it like it's not gonna just spread
out yeah and he's like yeah yeah I got
you but when he lit one he look he lit
it and then he comes to me goes
he's just freaking out because he just
started like traveling yeah so you could
have like a patch this bag you light it
just like yeah if it's gone but it
expanded here but then he didn't realize
it was connected to two things here and
he just went and just like it just Chain
Reaction you try to stomp it out before
you know it it's covering like you know
an area that you can it's like huge and
then it goes into leaves and like sticks
and just like you start having fire like
this High what it almost started a
Bushfire
well so what happened is probably like
it was like a long offense it was
probably like from that wall like twice
the length there there was like foot
long fire like flames and like maybe
like half the depth of this room to the
point where you're like you cannot stomp
us out you're the fire is just there did
it go out eventually so multiple people
came by it's really weird to think about
like the cars pulled up and they're like
oh no that's like a real fire like
should we call the fire department
they're asking 12 year olds or no we
were 11. to be like should we call the
fire department and we're like no no
we're putting it out they're like okay
and they just left what they just like
left and then this old lady came by and
we're like we asked like can we have
some water yeah yeah I think we've asked
another guy I don't live out here and
just left but like the lady's like okay
and she just walked so slowly and
eventually we got water from her by the
time we came back the fire was like yeah
it was so long so you're very lucky that
it kind of dissipated yeah but we
panicked but what the scary part was
behind it was like a chain-linked fence
holding all these leaves but behind it
was like multiple yards like backyards
of people that were filled with old
leaves and like thick amounts oh my God
people have wood decks we're like it
might have just burned people's houses
yeah yeah and so we kind of just
panicked and my friend was like I'm
never lighting a fire again and he just
threw his lighter into like the forest
and then it just set a place
we vowed to like never light a fire
again answer two years later we didn't
sleep properly for like probably like a
week well yeah because you guys were one
step away from being Arsenal so you very
quickly got over your trauma then only
took two years and you're back at it I
never really like
I kind of just stopped lighting things
on fire like I mean like for that period
I just didn't I just didn't like fire it
sound like it's something to be like
applauded like congratulations
arson is anonymous right now so so I've
been uh two years Fire free haven't let
anything on fire so I saw a match the
other day what was the moment where one
day your brain was just like I'm in a
lot of fun I made like so to to clarify
it's more like when people would be like
oh like I go to I was still pretty young
people like oh we're going to a family
friend's place they have a fire in the
backyard right I can't be like yeah I'm
not like I might not even go out and see
the fire like I was kind of just like I
brought back like a very negative
feeling I don't even want to be the
guilt that I didn't even want to own a
lighter because I not because I couldn't
help myself
just like literally holding it like
brought up so much like panic because I
I we literally thought we were gonna go
to like like kid jail yeah jail like
juvie or something yeah like we actually
thought because at the time both my
friend and I wanted to go to med school
we're like our lives would be to be over
yeah
oh I want to be in bed I was like our
lives would be over so like it
represented so much negativity I just
didn't even want to own matches or Alive
yeah yeah
um and then obviously like two years
later you're kind of like okay and kind
of there are situations where you like
you might be like you're at like I'm at
my parents house my mom's like here's
the lighter can you light the birthday
cake I'm not gonna be like no so it's
like just eventually I just it I got
over it yeah I don't really no just I
just stopped I mean it's also a kid
phase of just lighting things oh yeah of
course yeah it's like she hands you the
lights and you're staring yeah
it's like those horror movies where like
the whole room just like yeah